Let’s talk about anger
and pain in America.
By now we all know what happened.
George Floyd — an unarmed Black man
died after a white police officer kneeled on his neck.
For more than 8 minutes.
We’ve been here before
many, many times.
So how did we get here?
What’s behind that feeling of injustice?
Why are so many Black Americans
being killed by police?
And what has to change to make it stop?
This is about a lot more than one man’s death.
Or the deaths of so many other
unarmed Black people before George Floyd.
For the people protesting
this is about what it means to be Black in America.
The roots of that inequality run deep.
Slavery has been outlawed in America
for more than 150 years.
But that didn’t give Black people
equal opportunities or rights.
And it didn’t end the terror.
Between 1877 and 1950
there were more than 4,000 lynchings.
Racial segregation was only outlawed in 1964.
Black Americans were only guaranteed the right to vote
a year later.
Being Black came at a price then
and activists say it still does today.
And police violence against Black Americans
And then you look at the numbers.
Black Americans are a minority.
Just 13% of the population.
But in prison they make up 33% of all the inmates.
And if you’re an unarmed Black civilian
you are more than twice as likely as a white person
to be killed.
And police violence against Black Americans
well that happens a lot.
Rodney King was unarmed
when he was beaten by LA police
and left with brain damage.
Tamir Rice was playing with a toy gun in Cleveland
when he was shot by a police officer — 30 metres away.
Tamir was 12 when he died.
And Breonna Taylor — shot nine times
inside her own home in Louisville
by police executing a search warrant.
And it’s not just the police doing the killing.
Trayvon Martin was 17, unarmed
and killed by George Zimmerman
a neighbourhood watch co-ordinator in Florida.
The backlash to Zimmerman’s acquittal
gave rise to Black Lives Matter.
Ahmaud Arbery was out jogging in Georgia
when he was killed.
Three white men have been charged.
So why does it keep happening?
Why do so many Black people feel that law enforcement
and the justice system are failing them?
Let’s look at the broken window theory.
It was embraced by some police forces in the ’90s.
And the idea is that if you crack down
on the small things you prevent bigger crimes.
Now there are lots of studies that question
whether it actually works.
But what we do know is that it’s led to
more policing of poor neighbourhoods.
More police confrontations with minorities
more stopping, frisking and arrests of Black people
for things like graffiti, petty theft and drugs.
And then there’s the practice of sending officers
to police communities they’re not from.
No one, though, is saying policing isn’t tough.
The issue is that there’s a line between
keeping officers safe and the abuse of power.
They’re often trained to react quickly
maybe with force.
But rights activists say it can be hard
to hold officers accountable — for lots of reasons.
Police departments often investigate their own
when there’s a complaint.
Even if a case goes to trial the law says
“use of force must be judged
from the perspective of a reasonable officer”.
According to one advocacy group
only 1% of all killings by police
ever lead to an officer being charged with a crime.
That’s charged — not convicted.
Here are some more names.
NYPD officer Daniel Pantaleo
put Eric Garner in a chokehold that killed him.
He was never convicted of a crime but he was fired
five years later.
Police officer Darren Wilson shot and killed
18-year-old Michael Brown in Ferguson, Missouri.
He was eventually cleared of criminal charges.
“You’re threatening to drag me out of my own car?”
“Get out of the car!”
“And then you’re going to stun me?”
“Get out now!”
It’s why so many Black Americans
have been using their phones
to keep a record of what happened.
In the case of George Floyd several people recorded
the actions of those four police officers.
It took a while but all four were fired and charged.
So what is the way forward?
Well, many advocates are pushing for reforms.
Like getting the police to keep a record
of when they threaten civilians with a gun.
But change has been slow.
It’s what Colin Kaepernick was trying to say
when he took a knee.
It was a peaceful protest during the national anthem
and he was blacklisted for it.
Four years later people are still protesting
and people are still dying.
And right now there’s a lot going on in America.
Every so often there’s a new video circulating online
of white people calling the police on Black people.
“African American.”
In this one a woman calls 911
for being told to follow park rules
and put her dog on a leash.
“I’m going to tell them there’s an African American man
threatening my life.”
“Please tell them whatever you like.”
And it’s all come to a head during a pandemic
where report after report points out that
more Black Americans are dying from the virus
because of things like unequal access to healthcare
and poverty.
So many people are looking for leadership
from the very top.
But President Donald Trump, well, he has plenty of critics
who say he’s only making things worse.
But they’re not just appealing to the president.
Some people are hopeful and they’re determined
to make something of this moment.
Because families can’t get back what they’ve lost.
There’s a lot going on here.
We’ve barely scratched the surface.
But the message from protesters has been
no justice, no peace.
Justice and peace.
That’s the future they want for themselves.
And for America.
To ease some of that pain. Centuries of it.
That was just a primer.
It’s what we do on Start Here.
But there’s, of course, a lot more to this story.
The George Floyd case, violence at the protests
and of course the politics.
But we’re following all of those angles
on aljazeera.com and on our social media pages.
So make sure to follow, like and subscribe.
I’ll see you next week.